what is up guys fire here from awesome
toots dot-com let us now import the
assets for our new game that we are
gonna create as you can see I have a
brand new project this is a 3d project
so when you create a new project check
the check box or the radio button for 3d
name your project save it in any
location where you want to save it and
create it here I only have the scenes
folder with my gameplay scene which is
this scene right here which is
completely empty I did not import
anything I was waiting for you to watch
this video so now we are gonna go in our
assets folder that you can download in
the link below
and select all of these assets so we
have fonts materials models prefab
sounds and textures so drag and drop
them right here inside of the project
tab and of course we will need to wait
for unity to take mercy upon us and
import all of these assets so let us
wait one moment more no no no no no no
and finally they are here so in this
video I'm going to set up our main or
gameplay scene and we're gonna do that
by going inside of the prefabs folder
and here we have our level and here it
is I'm simply going to drag and drop it
here in the hierarchy panel and voila
this is our level I'm just gonna go here
with my mouse and see it and this is our
level now of course it looks like it's a
little bit dark but now it's a bit white
again so I'm gonna go quickly inside of
this aligning tab and I'm gonna uncheck
this out to generate and the Lightning
tab is under window and then here you
will see lightning and then you're gonna
click on the settings which will open
this tab right here it'll probably be
floating for you don't you try if I can
make it float No
not here yeah finally so it will finally
it will probably not finally be floating
for you like this
i dock it usually right next here to the
inspector panel on my right side and
when you select the lightning tab you're
gonna go right here inside or the bottom
of this lightning tab and you're gonna
uncheck this auto-generate now this
outer January notice here when I hover
over it says automatically generates
lightning data in the scene when any
changes are made to the Lightning system
this means if we take this directional
light and if I even change it a little
bit so if I change the rotation from
fifty to seventy one it will rebake
lightning it will try to simulate
lightning and that takes time that's the
reason why I have turned this off people
try to rebuild the Lightning settings
which will take a lot a lot of time for
us and we will need to wait your
computer will get hot so on and so forth
that's why I am going to turn it off now
we are going to duplicate this
directional light but first of all for
this light I'm gonna set the rotation to
ten like this and it already looks
pretty nice and the intensity I'm gonna
set it at one we can set at 1.5 for
example but one will do and I'm going to
duplicate it so I'm going to quickly
duplicate it here and this is
directional light one and also for this
one I'm going to set the rotation for
the y-axis at zero so the position X is
zero position Y is three Z rotation is
zero rotation X is 10 Y is 0 and Z is
zero this is for our directional light 1
for our direction light 2 so this one
right here I'm going to set the Y
rotation at 43 and do we want to set
here point three for the intensity or
something like this because now we're
casting shadows here on the side and of
course this all depends on the intensity
it depends
on the lightning I can also pump up the
intensity which will be something like
this which is something you use to kill
vampires in your game anyways I'm not
gonna go too much into lightning because
it is a separate topic on its own I talk
about this in the ultimate game
development Academy in a whole section
with a brand project or bad new project
so a separate project for talking about
lightning demonstrating how lightning
works so it's a separate topic for
itself but here I've just used this
directional light I can actually remove
this one so we can leave it at one you
can play with the intensity if you want
to but I will leave it at one and the
rotation is perfect I have turned off
the duplicate by the way and it looks
nice it looks pretty nice if I go in the
game this is how it looks like and by
the way for the main camera here it is
the z axis is going to be 0 the y axis
is going to be 1 something like this and
also the far for clipping planes I'm
going to set it it's 10 something like
this this what I did for the clipping
planes it will simply if I pump it up
pay attention to these parts right here
let me just demonstrate which parts do I
mean come on highlight tool where it is
here it is you see this from camera this
right here and this right here like what
the camera is seeing so pay attention to
that if I take my clipping planes and
place it far it means it will see as
long as the camera is stretching you see
as long as the camera is stretching we
don't need that much we only need 10 to
stretch the camera right here where our
plane is or our game field is and this
looks pretty nice this looks pretty nice
I'm pretty satisfied with this so we're
not gonna touch this anymore but we are
going to go and create our snake and I
am going to right click here and create
an empty game object like this
zero zero and this game object is going
to be our snakes I'm going to name it
snake now for our snake
we need to filter for our mesh which is
our eyeball mesh and here it is eyeball
I know I'm using an eyeball for our
snake but hey nobody's perfect so don't
judge me and I am simply going to take
this eyeball and put it here inside of
our game and we already see it is
casting shadows let me just clear this
console and here it is this is our
eyeball I'm going to take this one the
child one I'm going to remove this one
which is the parent one and I'm going to
put it as a child under our snake and
let me just position so zero zero zero
for our rotation I'm going to see here
or set it negative 19 so negative 90
zero for the y 180 for the Z for our
skill one one and one and by the way our
snake here we need to set the z axis let
me just five point eight something like
this for five point eight so now it is
visible and for our eyeball which is
going to be the head of the snake so
here I'm going to say head I'm going to
set it to point 12.12.2012 scale I did
not said what I'm going to set I'm going
to set the scale so select it and the
scale is going to be one point twelve
1.12 one point twelve now this is for
the head of our snake we are also going
to duplicate the head and I'm going to
put it here and this one is going to be
our node one I'm going to name node and
let me just move it right here and this
node I'm going to say it's point one
point one point one it needs to be
smaller than our head and let me just
duplicate it one more time and I'm gonna
put one a node as a child of our snake
parent game object
in this note I'm going to put it
somewhere here something like this now
that another the other note you didn't
move it here you just move it below so
let me just put this one a little bit
closer to our snake yeah this works
pretty nice and the last one is going to
be our tail so this is why I have
removed this one or this one is going to
be our tail and for the tail I'm quickly
going to add a sphere Collider and I'm
going to attach a rigid body on it so
attach a sphere Collider on this game
object this one that we named tail and
attach rigid body on it now uncheck this
use gravity because we don't want to use
gravity and duplicate it one more time
I'm going to rename it to simply tail
and put one of these as a child of our
snake now let me just zoom in and for
our tail here I'm going to set it at 0 0
and position it here something like this
so we are gonna position it to be as a
tail of our snake and for this one we're
going to save it in prefab so I'm gonna
go here and create a folder that I'm
going to call snake and inside of the
snake folder I'm going to drag and drop
this tail and now we can safely remove
it so tail can't be removed
and now this is our snake if I go into
gameplay scene you see this is our snake
so the tail is here it has a sphere
Collider and a rigidbody the node can
also have or it needs to have a sphere
Collider but we can uncheck it for this
node so for the second one the one after
the head we don't need the sphere
Collider to be checked and the rigid
body we are also going to add it and
uncheck use gravity by the way for the
tail also make sure that you check this
is trigger and do the same thing for
this tail right here check it to be a
trigger the tail right here I meant the
one that we dragged and drop into the
snake prefabs folder
for the snake's head which is this dude
right here now for this one we are also
going to attach a sphere Collider so
sphere Collider make sure it is a
trigger and I am also going to attach a
rigidbody and for this rigid body I'm
going to uncheck use gravity because we
do not need to use gravity for the rigid
body which we will see later on we will
demonstrate that when we start moving
because we are going to move from our
code and if we let gravity do the thing
it will pull us down which is something
that we don't want now for this sphere
Collider for the head we can actually
also uncheck it you you can uncheck it
because the top game object the top
parent this one the snake it will have a
sphere Collider and this sphere
colliders radius is going to be point
one or actually it is going to be one
and the center is going to be let's see
where it is just quickly let me see
where my spherical area so here it is
yeah it is large actually I need to
resize a little bit more going here
moving our sphere Collider yeah
something like this I need to resize it
more let's say Point 112 just so that I
can see where it is you see this green
line this is where our sphere Collider
is if I set it at zero I think this is
perfect yeah point one or point one one
is where we want this sphere Collider to
be I also am going to make it a trigger
cutting this is okay let me just try to
resize it a little bit soak it so that I
can see where it is radius yeah point
one one is for our radius of the sphere
Collider I'm also going to click on add
component and attach a rigidbody on this
dude right here and I'm also going to
uncheck this use gravity because we do
not need it we don't need it and this is
it
preparation for our game we have the
snake we have the level I'm gonna drag
and drop the snake in the snake prefab
folder so for the snake we have an empty
parent top game object we also have the
head which is this one right here or
this one right here the top one or the
largest part of the snake we have to
know this one I just named that node
because it's the second body part of the
snake and we have the tail so every next
game object that we add because you know
when we eat our fruit the game object or
the snake will grow larger it's the same
as on all Nokia phones when you use that
snake and you ate more and more the
snake grows larger and larger so all of
those other objects that we are going to
add the larger and larger Arabic objects
are our tails so the tail needs to be
named like this so that we can
differentiate it we have the head we
attach sphere colliders on all of them
so the tail and the sphere Collider fur
the tail needs to be checked it needs to
work because we can collide with the
tail you know the snake you can kill
itself if it touches itself so this is
for the tail for the note it does not
matter because we are not gonna do that
for the notes which is the next part
after the head head here it's also going
to have a rigidbody
all of these game objects have a
rigidbody except for the head and the
node the sphere Collider must be turned
off or we can also remove it and for the
snake we have the sphere Collider rigid
body which is the topmost game object
and this is preparation for our snake
moving forward with our game we have
prepared our level we added our snake we
added two directional lights we turned
one off now you can turn it back on or
turn it off this all depends on you
however you want to do it you can also
turn the first one or the second one off
and probably pump up the intensity on
the first one however you want to do it
it's up to you so I'm not going to touch
that I will turn the second one on so
both of them are turned on this is our
snake in the middle of our screen and we
need to
start moving the snake in order to do
that we need to go in our project tab
and right click and create a new folder
and this one is going to be our scripts
folder and inside of this one right
click and I'm going to create here
folder for helper scripts now for our
helper scripts the first script that we
need to create is our script that's
going to hold our tags so I'm going to
name it tags and first of all
right-click create a c-sharp script you
are gonna double click it and open it in
Visual Studio mana develop whichever one
you are using now since in our tags
class as you already know or assume we
will add tags and default variables that
we are going to use throughout our game
so I took the liberty to copy them
simply here and now you can pause the
video and simply paste them but before
you do that I am going to explain what
they are now here it's player direction
of direction without end anyways the
tags here will represent the tag so we
have the walls so when we collide with
them and we'll check if the collision
happened with a game object that has a
tag wall when we pick up a fruit we will
check that with the tag as well so these
are the tags for our game object and
here we can say tail with small T or a
il I wrote it all caps and for our
metrics so these are the metrics that we
are going to use to position and move
our nodes inside of our game or to move
the snake we will see that do not worry
about that and this is a public
enumeration to determine if we are
moving left up right down and this is
the count eg or it will show us how many
movements do we have so 1 2 3 and 4 so
we have 4 movements now as you can see
in our public enum we can say left is
equal to 0 up is equal to 1 right is
equal to 2 so we can do that as well
this is something that we
did not do before so I am showing you
that we can do it and why are we doing
it like this because later on we will
use these values so 0 1 2 & 3
to access indexes in our array so don't
worry about that you can pause the video
now and copy all of these tags metrics
and player direction and now I am
assuming that you have copied all of
those and I'm gonna move forward and go
in unity and in script I'm going to
right click and create a new C sharp or
actual new folder and this one is going
to be our player scripts and inside of
this folder I'm going to right-click and
create a c-sharp script now this one is
going to be our player controller this
is the dude who needs to be attached on
our snake so select the snake drag and
drop our player controller just like
this I'm going to double click it and
open it here in Visual Studio let me
just do my thing as always and this is
going to be the script that's going to
move the player we are going to create
another separate script for getting
input that means we will move the snake
or the player left right up and down and
for that we'll use a separate script
this script is the one that is going to
move the player and of course we need
here a couple of variables the first one
is going to be our public player
direction which I'm going to simply call
direction and since its public it will
be visible in the inspector panel I am
going to hide it in the inspector we
don't need it to be visible in the
inspector panel but we need it to be
public next we also need here and hide
an inspector public float step length
which is going to be equal to 0.2 F now
this is the movement interval so we are
going to move our game objects or the
snake by this movement in terribles of
0.2 now we don't want to move our snakes
every frame that
60 frames in a second so we don't want
to move it every frame so we need a
movement frequency so here I'm going to
say public float movement frequency like
this which is going to be equal to 0.1
and I'm also going to hide this bad boy
in the inspector now you see we're going
to move our snake every point 1 of a
second instead of moving it every single
time or 60 times in a second that's why
we need this movement frequency now we
also need a private game object which is
going to be our node prefab or actually
our tail prefab so you can name a tail
you can name it note however you want it
it is private it will be only accessible
here but we need to make it serializable
or serializable or serialized field
because we want to drag and drop our
tail if we go back here in unity and
notice here in the inspector we will see
an empty field to drag and drop this
game object for again it is located in
the prefabs and snake select here the
snake and drag and drop the tail right
here I'm also going to hit apply to make
changes to this prefab now this is why
we need to make it a serialized field
because we want it to be private but
still we need to drag and drop that game
object in side now we also need to store
the next position displacement based on
player direction and for that we are
going to use a private list of vector
threes which we are going to call Delta
position this is where we are going to
store the previous movement of our
player don't worry we'll see everything
in action we also need a private list of
rigid bodies which I'm going to call
nodes and this is going to be every
single separate node inside of the
snake's body that is snakes heads and
snakes tails so on and so forth we also
need a private vector3 and for this one
fruit node actually we don't need this
one so we are not going to you
this one but we are going to use a
private rigidbody for main body a
private rigidbody for the head body and
a private transform TR for our own
transform sword TR not transform we also
need private float counter and private
bull move now this counter we will use
it with the movement frequency to allow
the player to move and we can put these
two right here so that they are put with
the appropriate or right below the
appropriate variable that will accompany
them later on and the last variable that
we need is a private bull create node at
tail this will tell us do we need to
create a node at our tail that is when
we eat a fruit do we need to create a
node or not now instead of me explaining
all of these variables one by one what
they are I will demonstrate that so in
the awake so I'm going to change start
to awake in the away the first thing
that we're going to do is we are going
to say our TR is equal to our transform
TR is this one right here so we're going
to get it with our or our transform is
equal to TR next thing our main body is
going to be equal to get component and
get the rigidbody component from our
player and that is the top head or the
top main body of the snake so the top
parent which is the empty game object so
this one right here that we currently
have selected in the hierarchy we have
that one selected that is the or the one
that we are getting it's rigid body by
using getcomponent the next thing that
we need to do is we need to call here in
it cynic and nodes now this is a
function that we still did not create
and right below that function we are
also going to call init player and this
is also a function that we still did not
now let us go and create that right
below the update we're going to create
void in it snake and nodes now in this
one we are going to initialize the nodes
that means every single separate part of
the snake as you can see if I go inside
of the scene view you see we need to get
all of these nodes so we need to get the
head of the snake so this one we also
need to get this node the middle one and
the tail one so we need to get all three
of these so here in our in it snake
nodes we're going to see nodes which is
our array of rigid bodies or a list you
see here of rigid bodies and we are
going to make it a new list of rigid
bodies and below here we're going to say
nodes that add to add to that list and
we're going to say TR which is our
transform get child and we're going to
get the child that's at the zero index
dot get component so it's
component rigidbody component just like
this close parentheses and we're good to
go copy paste copy paste and we're going
to say child 1 and the child 2 and what
is going on here now before I explain
the last thing that we need to do is our
head body is equal to nodes and the
element that at index number 0 what is
going on here you see here we are using
TR which is our transform you see here
our TR is the transform get child and we
are getting the child what does this
mean
you see our transform the topmost
transform from our snake it has children
so we have the node or the head the node
in the tail and we know that or the
transform knows that we have children
assigned to it
so we can use or access those children's
by using indexes so you can say get
child 0 which means it will get the
first child or the child that's at
element 0 which is in our case head get
child 1 in our case it's the node get
child 2 in our case
is the tail and here notice the head
body it is the rigid body of the head
snake
so the rigid body of the head snake and
we know the head is set at index number
zero which I explained a moment ago now
in order to initialize our player so
right here below we are going to create
in it player simply here we are going to
make sure where our player is moving
left right or up or down so switch so
we're going to use a switch and we're
going to use direction and we are going
to use cases in our switching case so
we're going to have case player
direction a right and here we're going
to use break I'm going to copy this
paste it so we are going to have
direction left up and down and here I'm
going to simply say down so based on the
direction we are going to position all
of our nodes or shift them to that
position so if we need to or if our
starting position is the right position
we are going to do this so we're going
to say nodes and the element that's an
index one that position is going to be
equal to nodes in the element that's at
index 0 - new vector3 and here for our X
we are going to say metrics that note
and 0 F 0 F and for our for our nodes
number 2 or the element that's a number
2 and by the way here we need to say
note that position so the position of
our node 0 and by the way inside of our
nodes we are adding rigid bodies so when
we say position we are getting the
position of the rigid body you see here
when I hover over it says the position
of the rigid body so we are getting the
position of the rigid body and here we
are going to say nodes and the element
that's at index 2 now we are going to
say that position is equal to and we are
going to use
notes an element that's at zero dot
position - new vector3 and for our
metrics so we are going to say metrics
that note and we're going to multiply
that by 2 and 0 F 0 F what is going on
well when we start our game to the right
we need to shift the positions of our
game objects to the right side and in
order to do that we need to get the node
0 which is the head what we need to do
essentially if we are starting to the
right side that means when we start our
game that means when we start our game
we'll start moving to this side what we
need to do we need to shift the position
of this node over here and this node
over here because then we are going to
move to the right or actually to the
left side excuse me I'm moving to the
left but assume that I said left so if
we are moving to that left side we shift
their positions to the right side by
using + now let me demonstrate that so
I'm going to move them back here and
notice here if we are going to move to
the left so I'm simply going to copy
these lines of code and paste them here
instead of typing here - we're going to
say + you see here we are doing the same
thing except here we are doing that with
the plus sign so let me go back here and
demonstrate that with the left position
if we need to start moving to the left
position with arsenic that means we are
going to this side and we know that the
head so this bad boy over here he needs
to be at the top so he needs to be the
leading node in our snake in order to do
that we need to shift this node over
here and we need to shift this node over
here and this is exactly what we're
doing right here so if we need to move
to the left side use the node that's at
element 1 and use the element 0 node
which is the head and add to its
position the meth
Rick's node which is the displacement
that we saw here this is the
displacement of our nodes so this is how
far away they are from each other and do
the same thing for our second node
essentially this code right here is
going to position these nodes relative
to the node zero meaning and let me just
go back here meaning our head is the
relative position so our node here
this code right here is going to move
this node over here and this code right
here is going to move this tail node
over here this is what we are doing
essentially now we are going to do or
everything that we explained here for
the left side applies to the right side
except while the right side is opposite
to the left for our up side we are going
to do the same thing except for the
y-axis so for the Y side we are going to
say - but our metrics node is going to
be on the Y so 0 for the 0 F for X and
we are going to move that one on the y
and same thing here so we are just going
to take this and 0 F for the X and for
the Y metrics node x 2y x 2 because our
node at second position is our tail node
so we need to multiply that by 2 because
our head is here our node is here we
need to multiply this by 2 so 1 head is
1 node is 2 and multiply that by 2
moving that right over here this is why
we are multiplying with 2 for our down
position simply copy this code from the
up position paste it here and for the
down we are going to say plus like this
and voila we are good to go now of
course we need to create one more
function so right here above our in it
player we're going to create void set
Direction a random and here we are going
to say int Direction random or die
dir random is going to be equal to
random that range from
row up to you we need to say here int
and we're going to say player direction
that count to convert the count to an
integer because if we use it like this
without casting it to an integer and we
go back in unity we will see here best
of overloaded method match for random
rage float float we need to put this
into a float or an integer so I'm going
to use it like this because our account
if you remember has a value of four but
this is an enumeration and we can cast
this enumeration to an integer
I've talked this already once in one of
my tutorials can remember which one but
anyways we can cast it into an integer
because as I said the value is four so
the direction random will be based on
random range and notice here we are
casting this value to an integer and
simply here we're going to say Direction
is going to be equal to di are random
now same way as we can cast these enums
to an integer we can use enumerations to
cast integers to enum so we can see here
player Direction now based here on the
random value let's say random value is
equal to 1 so this di are int or di are
ran the value will have a value of 1
when we convert that into her into our
enumeration player direction and we go
back here the value 1 is up it will be
the same if the value is 2 so value 2 is
right if the value is let's say 3 then
the direction will be down now we do
need to call this right here so set
Direction random we need to call it
right above our switch in case statement
so we need to call it right there and we
need to go back here and we can unfit or
uncomment almost set on position we can
uncomment these functions now now pay
attention if we go back here I am going
to clear the console and we go here in
our game pay attention how the snake is
positioned say keys but it's positioned
with right direction in mind so it looks
like it's going to start moving this
direction notice now when we run the
game so I'm going to hit the play button
you see now it is positioned like it is
going to go downwards you see and if I
remove or stop the game and play it
again you see now it is positioned again
to the right side stop and rerun the
game it will be positioned now you see
like it is going upwards so this is how
we are moving these nodes relative to
the head node this is how are we
positioning these nodes by using these
lines of code right here now we are
still still not done here with the awake
function we need to create our delta
position or which to go or position in
which where we are going so our delta
position is going to be equal to new
list of vector threes like this open
close these curly brackets and here I'm
going to pass a new vector3
and here I'm going to see comma now for
the X I'm going to say negative step
length comma 0 F for the Y I'm going to
copy this and paste it below and here
I'm going to say 0 F first so 0 F and
here I am going to say step length comma
here paste this one right here now here
we are going to have positive step
length and I'm going to copy this and
paste it here now another comma here
remove this comma and here we're going
to have the negative length now right
here I am going to add comments and here
we need to end this statement with our
semicolon so I'm going to add comments
here like this so this one is going to
be our negative D X or going to the left
side here I'm going to put it like this
this one is going to be our D Y or going
to the up direction right here I am
going to say this one is going to be D X
or going to the right side and this one
and let me just move all of these by one
and this one is going to be our negative
D Y or this means going to the down
dier
so you see here this step linked this
one right here is actually the value or
we are going to move by that value so
this is the time interval that value
when we move we will move by zero point
two units this is what I'm trying to say
so when we have this right here this
means negative dy we are going to the
left side or negative x so to say here
we have the positive Y meaning up here
we have the positive X meaning right and
here we have the negative Y going down
and you see here negative Y positive x
positive Y negative x so this position
right here means we are going to the
left up right and this one is going down
now in order for us to actually move we
need to create a function that is going
to move us but before that we also need
to create a function here we need to
create a function that is void check
movement frequency and for this function
we are going to say here our counter so
counter plus equals time Delta time we
know the time that Delta time is a
difference between every frame so it's
the time it takes from one frame to go
to another frame and we're going to say
here if our counter is greater or equal
to movement frequency what we are going
to do we are going to see our counter is
equal to zero to start counting from
zero again and here we are going to say
move is equal to true to allow our game
object to move now in order to make it
move we are going to see here void move
or create a function that is going to
allow us to move and not on animator
move no simply void move and inside of
this function we are going to create
here a vector 3d position this is the
delta position we are going to use here
Delta position so it's actually Delta
position
and we are going to use that by using
here an int and we are going to pass
here the direction so the Delta position
or D position is our Delta position we
are casting the integer or direction to
an integer to get it as an index so
depending on the index if we are going
to the left side for example if you're
going to the left side index will be
zero meaning we will access element
that's an index 0 in the Delta in the
Delta position and if we go here in the
Delta position element that's at index 0
is left as you can see right here so now
that we have our Delta position what is
the next thing to do first of all we are
going to create here a vector3 parent
POS of parent position head body that
position and right below here we're
going to create the vector 3 preview or
the previous position and below here we
are going to say main body that position
is equal to main body position plus D
position right below we are going to say
head body that position is equal to head
body dot position plus the position
again now we are also going to move all
the snake notes so we're going to say
for int I which is equal to 1 as long as
1 or I is less than notes that count our
I is going to be plus plus and we are
simply going to see here previous
position is equal to nodes element
that's an index I that position storing
the previous position nodes and element
that's an index I that position is equal
to parent position and parent position
is now equal to previous position now
don't worry if I'm not explaining
everything in detail right now because
we will test it out soon do not worry
after we do all of this we need to check
if we need to not Trevor its check if we
need to create a new node because we
a fruit we will do that later on and for
that we're simply going to say if create
note at tail then we are going to write
the code to do that for us now
practically we are done for now and we
can test it out by going here in the
update function we are going to call
check movement frequency which is this
one right here comma go down this is
check moving frequency in the update we
are going to calculate our counter by
adding to it Delta time and if the
counter is greater or equal to movement
frequency then we will allow the
movement and in the fixed update right
below here so void fix update and let me
just remove this private because I like
it to be void simply and in our fixed
update we're going to check if move so
if we can move then move is equal to
false and we're going to call the
function move not fog mode move like
this thank you like this so in the
update function we are checking for the
frequency so counter plus equals time
Delta time if the counter is greater or
equal to the movement frequency then we
are going to see counter is zero so that
we can count from the beginning from
zero and move is equal to true in the
fixed update if move is equal to true
move will be false and move the snake by
one increment and in the move here this
is where we are going to move the snake
now in order to test that and see it in
action I am going to go back here in
unity and run the game and we're going
to see the movement of the snake and
then we will go and break it down a line
by line so when I hit the play button
pay attention to you the snake you see
snake is moving by one increment it is
gone we cannot control the snake notice
now if I hit the play button now a snake
is going downwards just a moment ago
first time when we test it out snake was
moving upwards I'm going to hit the play
button again hopefully it will move left
or right to know again
moving down or up come on try to move
left or right just for once okay now it
is moving to the left side and you can
test it out as long as you don't see it
moving left right up and down but this
definitely works we see it now let me
try one more time hopefully it will go
to the right side no anyways let's go
break it down line by line so these here
are now getting a clear picture or we
are understanding for what we are using
this direction is going to determine in
which direction our snake is going to go
step length is the frequency or the
units measurement unit by how much units
we are going to move every node that is
point two units movement frequency is
the how many times we can move in a
second so every point one of a second we
can move counter is used to test that
out so we are adding to our counter the
Delta time we know that is the it's a
very small number so the difference or
the time it takes from one frame to go
to another frame so that's a very small
number and when that counter value is
greater or equal to the movement
frequency which is this value right here
then we will allow our snake to move so
counter is reset back to zero and move
is equal to true and moving forward this
is our tale prefab which we will use
later on when we eat a fruit or when the
snake eats the fruit we will add to the
snake so it's get it gets larger and
larger this is the Delta position and
you see here Delta position is the
direction where we are going is it left
is it up right or down and we're using
that by well using the step length and
these values right here you see here the
negative step length is negative X
meaning we are going to the left side
positive Y that means up and positive
step length that means going to the
right side negative Y means we're going
down now here are the nodes that we are
going to get when we initialize the
snake basically these are the rigid
bodies of every part of the
so the head the note in every part of
the tail so we can have 20 tails when we
eat 20 fruits every single one of those
tails is going to be added to this node
array you see here we're using the
transform to get the child's so we are
getting the child at index zero one and
two child at zero index or at 0th index
is our head so we are doing or assigning
that right here and moving back here we
have the main body head and transform so
the main body is our main body or the
top parent or the parent of all game
objects so this one right here the snake
that's the main body our TR is the
transform and here we are initializing
the snake nodes by getting the rigid
bodies from every child next we are
initializing the player that means we
are setting the direction the initial
direction of the movement of the snake
we're doing that with this function
which is this one right here so you're
using a random range from zero and
direction that counts so player
Direction count we are casting that to
an integer because the value here of the
count is equal to four as you can see
here count is equal to four so when we
cast it to an integer it will display
that value so it will display four which
means a random range from zero or
between zero and four and when we get
that random range let's say that number
is three we will cast it back to player
direction so if the value is three three
is down if the value is for example two
then two is right and you get the
picture so we are assigning that to the
direction now when we do that in this
function based on which direction we
have is it right left up or down we will
displace these nodes and we saw that we
have previewed that so let's say for
example if the initial position is
moving to the left side if I hit here
pause and I'm going to zoom in on our
snake I'm going to hit the play button
you see here the initial direction was
left side which means both of these
this one here and this one here shifted
to the right side by using these lines
of code so using the head position of
our snake as orientation and we're
adding to that position this value here
now metrics node is this one right here
this is the increment or the stepped
length this the same as step length and
for our second node we need to multiply
that by two because we need to also
place it after our middle node because
we have three nodes same applies for
right up and down now moving forward
here we have our check movement
frequency we have explained this so we
are adding to the counter Delta time
when the counter is greater or equal to
the movement frequency reset counter
move is equal to true this happens in
the update function in the move function
we are getting the Delta position
meaning the direction where we are
moving so we are moving by using Delta
position which is our array that we
create right here and we are casting to
an integer the direction if the
direction is for example or the value of
the direction is 2 that means we are
moving to the right side next we are
getting the parent position which is our
head body position and we are storing
the previous position now first we need
to start moving the main body which is
the main body of our snake the top
parent holding all nodes and we are
going to move it by using or setting its
position to be equal to its current
position plus the delta position or the
direction where we are going so the
direction position we're doing the same
thing with the head body so head body's
position is equal to head bodies current
position plus the direction where we are
doing now depending on if we are going
to the left we are going to plus and the
value for the left let me just see here
the value for the left is the negative
step length and 0 for device so it will
move it to that direction now we have to
move all of our nodes we moved our head
already
that's why int I
is equal to one because here if you paid
attention the element or the first node
is the node at element zero which is our
head node and we already set the head
body or the head node we moved it so now
what we need to do is move all other
nodes that's why I start at one and not
at zero and we are going to move how
many nodes we have if we will have 100
nodes then we are going to use count
which will be 100 so we will move 100
nodes now the previous position and we
are getting that by using the node at
the current eye index in its current
position this is the previous position
the new position for that node is the
parent position so the parent position
that we had here for our head and now
the parent position is equal to the
previous position because the next node
will be repositioned by using that same
position and the outcome for that is if
we go in our unity and if we hit the
play button you will see how our snake
is moving come on unity please have
mercy upon us so if I hit the play
button again you will see that the snake
will move in the increment or using
incremented values or if we go here the
step length that is this is how many
units it will use two moves moving
forward with our game we have the snake
moving and it is moving in a certain
direction the problem is that we cannot
control that we cannot control the
movement of the snake when the game
starts so when we press any button we
will not change the direction of the
snake so in order to fix that inside of
our player scripts folder we need to
right click and create a new c-sharp
script which we are going to call player
player input
in this script we need to attach on our
snake right here so drag and drop our
player input hit apply so that this
change applies to the prefab and
double-click it and open it in Visual
Studio man I'm in saying open it in
monodevelop but hey people change
using Visual Studio I have changed
anyways moving forward what do we need
for our player input the first thing is
our player controller so we need a
private player controller that we are
going to call player controller of
course this is because we need to inform
the player controller that we change the
direction where the snake needs to move
now we are also going to create a
private int horizontal which by default
is equal to zero and vertical which by
default is equal to zero as well we also
need to create a public enumerations of
public enum that I'm going to call axis
and you can assume which axis do we have
so we have horizontal and we have
vertical because well we have two axis
no inside of our start function we can
get our player controllers so player
controller is equal to you get component
get component player controller
component like this and this can be done
in the awake function as well so you can
choose to put this in the awake if you
want to we can leave it at awake because
we are only getting here our player
controller because I like to initialize
my variables in the awake function more
than I like to initialize them in the
start function now inside of the update
the first thing that we need to do is
that we need to get our player input but
before that we need to say horizontal is
equal to zero and vertical is equal to
zero to reset their values and now in
order to get that input we need to call
a function that we did not create that
I'm going to call it get keyboard input
like this and right below here we are
going to created by typing void in the
name of the function which is get
keyboard input and now inside of our
keyboard input we're simply going to say
horizontal is equal to
and we need to say input that get access
or raw and here we are going to see
horizontal and for our vertical we are
going to see vertical is equal to input
that get access or raw and it is going
to be vertical but we have an error what
is this error if I hover over it says
cannot implicitly convert the type float
to an integer the problem is that this
returns a float you see this right here
this input get access raw returns a
float so we need to cast it to an
integer by typing in parentheses int in
front of it and the same thing we need
to do it right here so we are casting or
converting this float into an integer so
we have here our horizontal and vertical
we do need to test if our horizontal is
not equal to null then we need to say
our vertical so vertical is going to be
equal to zero like this and why do we
why did we type this here well if we
move horizontal we need to set vertical
at zero and this is to prevent double
movement so just to prevent double
movement this is why we are doing it
like this now in order to test this out
we need to create a function that we
will still did not create and this
function let me just type this out here
I remove this curly bracket now right
below our get keyboard input we need to
create void set movement and inside of
our set movement we are going to move
our game object but you are going to do
it or call it right here right below our
gift keyboard input now inside of our
set movement here we are going to say if
our vertical is not equal to zero then
we are going to call our
playercontroller to change the movement
but in order to change that movement we
need to go here in our player controller
right below our check movement frequency
we need to create a public void set
in put direction which takes a player
direction dir as a parameter now first
of all in this function we need to
prevent movement in the opposite
direction what does that mean it means
that if we are moving up we cannot start
moving down we cannot start moving down
or if we are moving left we cannot start
to move to the right side and vice versa
so we need to say here if our dir is
equal to player Direction up and our
direction is equal to your player
direction down or if our dir is equal to
player direction dot down and our
direction is equal to player Direction
up you see my point because we cannot
move in the opposite side because if the
let me quickly go here in unity and if I
take my snake in the scene let's assume
snake is moving in the right side like
this we cannot press left and it will
start moving left now we cannot do that
we need to start moving up and then move
left or down and then move left this is
my point
that's why we are testing this and we
need to say here as well if di r is
equal to player Direction that right and
Direction is equal to player direction
that left or if di r is equal to player
direction that left and direction is
equal to player direction right so if
this is true if some of these is true
then we are going to hit return and not
rect transform or whatever that was if
one of these is true and notice we are
using or so only one of these needs to
be true so if Direction is equal to or
dir is equal to up and dir is the
parameter so if d IR is equal to up and
Direction is equal to down
and that is true we cannot move to the
opposite side same thing goes for down
and up right and left left and right but
if this right here is not true then we
are simply going to say Direction is
equal to D I are now direction is our
own variable that we are using here let
me just find it here it is our direction
we talked about it in the previous video
so Direction is equal to the parameter
that we put here now we also need to
force move so we need to see here force
move our game object or our snake now
our force move we're going to create it
so force move and simply in our force
move we are going to say counter is
equal to zero move is equal to false and
move call our function to you move the
snake immediately without waiting for
the next movement frequency threshold
well I will because when we press the
button we want to move the snake right
away we don't want to wait for the
movement frequency threshold to kick in
so that we can actually start moving the
snake so right away when we press the
button and this is what we are doing
here so we are resetting the counter
move is equal to false and we will call
move to right to move the snake right
away now going back to our set movement
now if our vertical is not equal to zero
we are going to say player controller
that set input direction and here we are
going to test if our vertical is equal
to one question mark then we are going
to say player direction that up call on
player direction that down what are we
doing here what is going on well you see
here we are testing if vertical is equal
to no this essentially this code right
here and let me just take this code so
this code right here that we did and let
me just put it right here so that
can actually see it this is what we are
doing pay attention here
so if our vertical is equal to one and
we are using or questioning that or
asking that with a question mark so if
it's equal to one and that is true then
the value will be up otherwise the value
will be down this is essentially if as
if we are doing this let me just put
like this and this is essentially same
as if we typed if vertical is equal to 1
then our player Direction is equal to
player Direction up so player Direction
up else if vertical is not equal to 1
then player Direction that down this is
what we are asking with this right here
so if the verticals value is equal to 1
then we will set Direction up which is
logical because vertical that means that
we will go upwards on the y-axis if and
just go back Wow why is it taking me
over there anyways otherwise if our
vertical is not equal to 1 this is for
this we are using this : so if it's not
equal to 1 and let me just go back here
so if it's not equal to 1 that means
that we will use Direction down for the
value meaning we will go down now here
we are going to say else if else if our
horizontal is not equal to 0 we're going
to do the same thing so we're going to
say player controller that set input
direction and here we're going to say
horizontal is it equal to 1 question
mark and right here we're going to say
player Direction that right call on
player direction that left it's the same
thing except for our horizontal so it's
exactly the same thing now we can test
this out but we will have one problem
and we will see what that problem is so
if I go back here I am going to clear
the console and I'm going to hit the
play button and notice now we can change
the
direct you see we can change the
direction but you see the snake is
moving like crazy as long as if we are
holding our mouse are actually our
keyboard I'm pressing W key ASD or left
arrow right arrow up you see the snake
is moving like crazy like some crazy
parasite that came from out of Earth you
know alien parasite and it's trying to
get into you now we don't want this we
don't want this kind of movement we have
this movement because we are using input
get access raw now this is not something
that we want so I'm going to comment
this out we need to create another
function that will get us the movement
of the snake now here we're going to
create a function that will return an
integer and we're going to call it get
access or raw which takes an axis and
I'm going to call it axis as a parameter
and it takes this axis that we created
this enumeration right here now right at
the bottom of this function we are going
to return zero if nothing happens
because we need to return an integer but
what we are going to do here is that we
are going to test if our axis is equal
to access that horizontal so we need to
check for the horizontal axis then we
are going to say bull left is equal to
input that get key down did we press a
key down and that is going to be key
code key code that left arrow and bull
right is going to be input that get heat
down and this is going to be key code
that all right arrow like this so we are
going to get here the boolean for the
left and the right now you can do the
same thing for our W a s d I'm using
here arrows so pay attention because we
will use arrows left arrow right up and
down arrow on your keyboard to move our
snake now you can do the same thing or W
key
ASD and to move that that snake with
those keys so here I'm going to say if
left meaning if we pressed the left
arrow key then here we are going to say
return return negative one because we're
moving to the left side if right then we
press the right arrow key we're going to
say return one like this otherwise we
are going to say return no like this
else if so else if our axis is equal to
ax is that vertical so we need to check
for the vertical axis then we're going
to say bowl up is equal to input that
get key down and we are testing for key
code so get key down and it's key code
that up arrow our ball down is equal to
input that get he down and he killed
that down arrow and same thing so we
need to test it like this so we need to
say here if up so if up we pressed the
up arrow key we are going to return 1 if
down then we are going to return a
negative 1 so return -1 otherwise return
0 or return null I'm saying null for 0
but actually it's return 0 so this is
what we are doing and let's go inside
our keyboard input and right here our
horizontal is going to be equal to get
access a raw passing here access that
horizontal our vertical is going to be
equal to get access raw passing our axis
that vertical so it's vertical like this
voila so if we go back now in our unity
and if I press the play button and
notice now if I try to move you see the
snake I'm holding the
UP button so I'm holding these buttons
and I'm pressing for the snake to move
but the snake is not moving like crazy
like you did a moment ago and notice
here pay attention now you see the snake
is moving and let me just go and
demonstrate this
so in our playercontroller if i
uncomment or actually comment these
lines of code out you will see how this
helps us preventing the snakes movements
so pay attention now if the snake is
moving you see now we cannot move it
like this you see it's moving to the
left and now we're changing it to move
to the right or now down and now it's
moving up you see we cannot move it like
this we cannot move the snake like this
because the snake then we'll hit itself
and it will die because remember if the
snake or in the snake game on old Nokia
phones or any snake game when the snake
hits its own tail it is that long to put
back Wow how are you want to call it
anyways it is dead the game is over so
that's why we are preventing the
movement in the opposite direction
because now if I am moving for example
to the left side I cannot press right to
move so I'm praying I'm moving to the
right and I'm pressing left it's not
working I'm moving to the left pressing
right from moving up pressing down it is
not working we need to turn left or
right and then move to that side where
we want to move and also let's go and
briefly break down all of these codes
now this right here it's pretty clear
this is clear what it is this right here
as well here we are resetting horizontal
and vertical every time after the input
and here we're getting that input now
pay attention here we are using
horizontal and our function get access
raw and here get access raw here
horizontal here vertical this is clear
as well so here when it's horizontal we
are checking for get key down if we
press our key code down for the left
error or the right error we will store
that in these boolean if we press the
left or if we pressed right we will
return negative 1 or 1 depending on
which
these we have pressed otherwise we will
simply return zero same thing for the
vertical axis if we press keycode up or
down this will trigger or it will set
the appropriate boolean out of these two
to be true if we press up will return
one if we press down we will return
negative one because down on the y axis
is negative up is positive on the left
side for the horizontal left is negative
right is positive we did this probably
thousands of times in my tutorials on
youtube channel in the ultimate game
development Kadim ii and i talked about
this thousands of times and this is
basic math if you go to the left side on
axis it is the negative side right side
is the positive up is positive down is
negative so moving back inside of our
get keyboard input we are storing that
value in the horizontal so it will be
either 1 or negative 1 or 0 and here we
are checking if our value is not equal
to 0 so we need to check if it's not
equal to 0 because if it's equal to 0 we
are not moving so we are not moving if
it's equal to 0 so if it's not equal to
0 it's either 1 or negative one if
vertical is equal to 1 then we will set
it up which means positive if it's not
equal to 1 meaning it's negative 1 then
it's down same thing for the horizontal
and in our playercontroller we created
set input direction we are preventing
here moving to the opposite side and we
tested this out a moment ago and when
that happens we're setting the direction
to our own or dir this parameter to our
own movement direction and then force
move the snake just so that it moves
right away instead of waiting for the
threshold of the movement frequency
moving forward with our snake we can
move it and we can control it so let us
now detect collision on the walls and
also add our collectibles now first of
all we're going to start with our walls
and if we go here in the level we have
these walls right here so all of these
walls and let me select all of them so
we have top laws we have bottom walls
left and right walls select all of these
walls except don't select their parents
so bottom walls this one right here left
walls and right walls we don't need to
select these so select all of the vols
except for their parents as you can see
I did not select top walls game object
bottom walls left walls and right walls
because we are using that as a parent to
store all of these children so now when
we have all of these we are simply going
to click on add component and we are
going to add a mesh Collider so mesh
Collider component on all of these which
we can detect collision on them and I am
going to tag them so click here on add
tag and I'm going to create a wall tag
I'm also going to create a fruit tag and
a bomb tag so select again all of these
walls except for their parents so select
them except the parents and tag them
with the wall tag and voila we are good
to go and also for these obstacles here
which are these as you can see so these
right here if I turn them off so these
also set their tag to be wall and I'm
going to select 11 and level and hit
apply so that this change applies to the
prefab and if we go inside of our
playercontroller and right here inside
of our void on trigger enter in our
ontriggerenter we can test if we
collided with the wall except here for
other I'm going to say target because I
like to name this parameter target and
I'm going to say if our target dot tag
is equal to tags that wall we are simply
going to print here so print touched
wall like this so we touch the wall and
that is that this is just for testing
purposes we will fix this later on do
not worry about that so if I go back
here in unity and if I try to collide
with some of
these wall obstacles pay attention in
the console so now when I hit one of
these BAM we should see inside of our
console that we have collided with the
wall now of course we collided with the
top walls but we are not colliding with
the obstacle walls that is because we
need to select them as well and attach a
mesh Collider on them we forgot to do
that so if I hit the play button again
and if I go through these walls that our
obstacle walls band you see touch the
wall touched wall touched wall when we
go through all of these so this is
working we are detecting collision
between our walls and now moving back in
our project we are going to import the
bomb and the fruit now here I'm going to
filter for the eyeball in our project
and drag and drop the eyeball right here
and I'm going to filter for the bomb and
I'm going to drag and drop the bomb also
in our hierarchy panel and inside of our
prefabs I'm going to right click and
create a folder and this is going to be
our pickups so pickups where we are
going to store the eyeball and the bomb
and here actually I'm going to name the
eyeball to fruit and bomb balls simply
to bomb I'm going to tag the fruit with
the fruit tag and bomb with the bomb tag
I am also going to remove the animation
from the bomb and for the fruit remove
the animation as well I am going to
change the scale of the fruit to point
one point one point one the z axis is
going to be five point eight and we are
going to attach a sphere Collider on it
and actually let me just take this fruit
so eyeball this fruit right here and I'm
going to name this game object here as
fruit and this one I'm going to save
point one point one point one rotation
I'm going to say zero this rotation
negative 90 and on this one I'm going to
attach a sphere Collider make it trigger
and let me just see where it is here it
is this is our eyeball or our fruit that
we are going to use as a fruit that is
and I'm going to tag it here with the
fruit tag come on selected where it is
fruit not bomb what is wrong with me so
tag it with the fruit tag and for the
bomb I'm also going to change that so
I'm going to save point to point to
point to the Z position five point eight
for the bomb and here is our bomb we are
also going to attach a sphere Collider
on the bomb and voila this is it
so if we go inside of our prefabs and
pickups I'm going to drag and drop the
fruit and I'm going to drag and drop the
bomb prefab if we go back in unity here
if we touch the wall I'm also going to
see or if our target tag is equal two
tags so tags
come on tags that bomb we are also going
to print now touched bomb because we're
going to check if we touch the bomb now
for our fruit we are going to do the
same thing so we're going to say if our
target dot tag is equal two tags that
fruit tag and here we are simply going
to deactivate it so we're going to say
target dot game objects at active is
false and we need to see create a node
at the tail is now equal to true because
remember here we are going to create a
tail because we picked up a fruit so we
need to create a tail now first of all
we are going to test if this actually
works and then we will see how can we
create that tail so first of all we are
going to pick up the bomb and see if we
are printing in the console that we are
picking or picked up the bomb so BAM we
touched the bomb that is good we will
end the game when we touch the bomb now
we are going to pick up the fruit and
when we pick it up BAM it is gone but we
need to
create a node at tail or make the snake
larger because we are we picked up a
fruit so if I go back here in Visual
Studio this now is true create node a
tail is now true so when we go back here
this is where we need to create that so
first of all when this is true we are
going to say create node a tail is now
equal to false because we only want to
create node a tail once we don't want to
create it multiple times and if we
continue what is the next thing to do is
that we need to create a game object so
we need to say game object and we need
to say new node is equal to instantiate
and we are going to instantiate the node
prefab or tail prefab and we can see
here new tail or new tail or new no the
actually new node field prefab and we
are going to instantiate it where where
we are going to instantiate it using
nodes and we are going to say notes that
count - 1 dot position position dot
quaternion identity like this and let me
just move quite on your identity here
what are we doing here we know that in
our instantiate we need to pass a game
object that we want to instantiate or
create a copy out of that game object we
need to pass a position and we need to
pass a rotation rotation is not
important quaternion identity 0 0 0
what's important is the position notice
here I'm using nodes and nodes count
minus 1 dot position this is the last
node in the nodes array that we are
storing here and remember in the
beginning we stored 3 nodes our head our
middle node and our tail and I said
every new tail node will be stored
inside of this nodes array because we
need to keep track how many do we have
and if I go back here what is the next
thing to do we need to say new node that
transform that set parent and we need to
set our own transform and here we're
going to say
you see here world position if world
position stays true the parent relative
position scale and rotation are modified
such that the object keeps the same
world space position rotation and scale
as before so when we see here true it
will simply make this node keep the same
position same skill and everything
relative to its parent and here are
simply going to see nodes add and we are
going to append to it new node that get
component and we're going to append the
rigidbody component like this because I
said we are going to add every new node
inside of this array now we can see this
the best way to see this is if I copy
and paste a little bit or multiple of
these fruits so we can have one fruit
here I'm going to duplicate in one fruit
here one fruit here for example one
fruit here and one fruit here just so
that we can see that our snake is
growing larger so now we have three of
our snakes or three parts of our snakes
now we just have four you see now we
have four and five you see the snake is
bigger and notice now again picking up
these you see the snake gets bigger and
bigger again picking one one more one
more the snake is bigger and the bigger
we pick up all of these you see we
picked up all of these nodes and you can
see that every single one of those nodes
are actually those fruits are being
appended at the end of the snake because
we are using nodes and nodes count we
are getting the element that's at the
count minus one which is the last
element inside of that array so the last
element inside of that array we are
getting that and we are positioning we
are positioning that node at that
position so if the last node let's say
if I highlight or use my highlight tool
so this is the head of the snake this is
the node this is the tail and this is
another tail so let's say we
eat a new node or new fruit here so we
eat it nom nom nom and now we want to
append it to the snake so the snakes
position or the snake grows larger so
this node needs to go here that's why
we're using this right here nodes count
so this right here position which is the
last position count minus one it's the
last element in the array which is this
one and its position so we are using its
position to set it so append that right
here so appended right after that
position this is what we are doing and
basically that is that what we can also
add here is that now we can say if so
here we can say or if our target dot tag
is equal two tags that tail tag so if we
touch our tail so you're also going to
say print snake touched tail and if I go
back here we need to make sure that our
snakes last part has a tail you see here
it needs to have a tail tag so add tag
and here we are going to say tail tag so
select it and this one will have a tail
tag hit apply and if we go back here for
our snake if I select it and the tail
that we add here this tail also needs to
have the tail tag because the snake will
die if it hits itself and notice if I
pick up some of these fruits and when we
pick it up the snake will get larger and
larger so then we can touch our own tail
notice now we touch our own tail you see
here snake touch and I spell touch with
douche so snake touch the tail you see
we touched tail and bam we should die
when we touch our tail but we will do
that later on don't worry about that the
point is that this all is working we can
remove all of these fruits so let me
select all of these fruits we can remove
them we are only left to create our
gameplay controller who is going to
spawn all of these fruits in our level
son and
so forth and also create audio effects
but before we end this video I'm also
going to create our UI quickly because
our UI is not going to be that large so
if I go here in our game our canvas is
going to be set on screen split screen
space overlay I'm going to scale it with
screen size 180 by 720 and I'm going to
match the width and height equally I'm
going to take the image this is going to
be our icon so snake icon and I'm going
to set the anchor at the top middle I am
going to set here for the source image
this snake portrait or however we are
going to call it the width and height is
8080 for this snake the position X is
negative 99 and the position Y is
negative 5/8 like this and the next
thing we are going to add our separator
so I'm going to take here I'm going to
actually rename this one as well UI
canvas I'm going to hit here right-click
and you I text now this text is not
going to be a child of our snake icon it
is going to be a regular text I'm going
to call it separate or separator and I'm
going to simply add this line to
separate and we will see what we will
separate I'm going to set the font at
Arial and let me just resize that I'm
going to set the anchor at the top
middle the width is 29 and the height
will be 135 the position X will be
negative 32 and the position Y is
negative 49 the skill or the font size
is 103 and I am going to set the color
to white and voila this is it and
actually we can move it just a little
bit down something like this
yeah this can do so negative 62 negative
62 can do and voila this is our
separator now I named it separate tone
it's separator and we are also going to
create a score so here instead of
separator I'm going to call it score now
for the school
our top anchor the width is going to be
303 the height is going to be 83 the
position X is going to be 1/5 1 and the
position Y is going to be negative 60
and here I'm simply going to say score
like this zero and let me just find it
where it is where is my score where did
I put it yeah here it is here is my
score
and let me just resize the font
something like this so the font can't be
50 here in this case I'm going to set
the font at 50 and maybe just move the
score a little bit down negative 72 so
negative 72 for our score now the font
for our score is going to be our open
son's irregular open son's regular here
it is
and voila that is practically that this
is going to be our score or maybe just
move a little bit so negative 6 9 this
works perfectly so this is our UI here
is where we are going to keep track of
the score this is our snake image this
is the separator between the snake image
and the score not that fancy because the
point is not to create fancy you I
depend the point is to create our snake
game also make sure that you attach or
drag and drop the bomb inside of our
pickups so drag and drop the bomb and
the fruit to make them prefabs a lot of
wrapped things up
starting with our game play controller
so in the scripts folder and helper
scripts I am going to right click and
create our game play controller like
this and I am going to right click here
in the hierarchy and create an empty
game object which I'm going to name game
play so it's game play controller so
game play controller and I'm going to
attach the script on the game play
controller what do we need well as
always we need a couple of variables to
start with
let me do my thing so let me tag the
class give a little bit of space the
first thing we are going to make our
gameplay controller and instance so
public static gameplay controller
instance like this and for our instance
right here instead of our update I'm
going to create create create make
instance and inside of this one I'm
simply going to say if instance is equal
to null meaning it's not pointing
anywhere I'm going to say instance is
equal to this and voila we are good to
go
I'm also going to call this function in
the awake function as always so this is
nothing new we did this probably
thousands of times so far before moving
forward I am also going to type here
using unity engine dot u I because we
need to get ourselves some reference to
that text displaying the score to our
user and we are going to display the
score every time our snake eats a fruit
so here we also need a public game
object for our fruit pick pop now this
is not a pickup truck it's simply a
fruit and we also have a bomb pick up
like this now also we are going to have
a private float this is going to be our
minimum underscore X which is equal to
negative 4.25 F we are also going to
have maximum X which is equal to 4.25 F
now the minimum is negative and a
positive or the maximum is positive
minimum Y which is equal to negative two
point twenty six F and positive or
maximum Y which is equal to two point
twenty six F and also our private float
Z underscore P OS which is equal to five
point eight F what is all this here what
did i just type am I going crazy or not
well first of all we need to make sure
that we are going to spawn our fruits
and the bomb between our
game objects here let me just find the
level here it is
so between when I said between our game
objects I meant between here and here so
as you can see this point let me just
take it again so this point here is for
point or let me just find it it's
negative for point 25 so negative for
point 25 which is somewhere around here
and this one is positive for point 25
which is somewhere around here how did I
find these values well I just did as you
just saw I took this fruit or this eye
and I positioned it here and saw which
position that was then position it here
and saw which position that was did the
same thing for y-axis and voila this is
how I got them now our fruit and bomb in
the scene we can remove them because
we're going to drag and drop if I suck
the gameplay controller we will go in
prefabs and pickups and we will drag and
drop these from our prefab so fruit
pickup will go here and bomb pick up
will go right here so moving forward or
going back here and z position is same
as for all of our game objects you can
see snake has Z position five point
eight so does every other game object
that we want it to be visible so moving
forward we also need a private text
which is going to be our score text and
we need a private int which is our score
count now inside of the start function
we are going to say so void start and
here we are going to see our score text
is equal to game object find the game
object with the name score get the
component text from that game object
like this and we are good to go now you
need to make sure that the name of that
game object is indeed score so in our UI
here so UI canvas here it is score so
make sure the names match up or
otherwise this will not work now we are
going to create functions that are
going to start spawning our pickups be
that a bomb or our fruit so first of all
we are going to create an eye enumerator
a co-routine as you might assumed and
we're going to call it spawn pick ops
like this so start spawning pickups and
here we're going to say yield return new
wait for seconds and we are going to
wait from a random dot range between 1 F
and 1.5 F so between 1 second in 1.5 of
a second we're going to wait and then we
will spawn either a fruit or a bomb and
we're going to do that using a random
value so if random range from zero to
ten is greater or equal to two then we
are going to instantiate a fruit so here
we're going to say instantiate and we're
going to pass here our fruit pickup at
the position new vector3 like this and
for our X we're going to say random that
range from minimum X to maximum X this
is for the x position for the Y position
random that range from maximum or
minimum Y to maximum Y and our Z
position so zpos comma quaternion
identity and we are good to go
so let me just put a quaternion identity
right below here and voila we are good
to go this is for spawning R and
actually I'm also gonna put new vector3
right here and put this right here so it
works perfectly like a charm so
instantiate the fruit pickup on the
random range between minimum X and the
maximum X minimum Y and the maximum Y
and I've explained this it will
instantiate our game object so I'm going
to take it like this and zoom in on our
level just a little bit something like
yes and I'm going to take the highlight
tool just so that I can demonstrate that
this is the minimum X and this is the
maximum X value minimum or maximum Y and
this is the minimum Y so between random
range between minimum and maximum that's
this range so between here so between
these two values here it will spawn it
on the x axis and on the y axis it will
spawn them between these values as I
explained a moment ago how are we in
stanching or how did I get those random
values so this is if random range is
greater or equal to two because there is
only 20% chance that we will spawn a
bomb if that happens then here we are
going to copy this line of code and here
in the else statement instead of fruit
pickup we're simply going to say bomb
pickup and voila
that is that but we need two more
functions because here above we are
going to create void sock start spawning
like this so start spawning and here
we're simply going to say start kill
routine and we're going to start our
spawn pick obscure routine which will
start while this coyote but here inside
of this Co routine we are also going to
call invoke and we are going to invoke
this function like this so you see here
we are invoking this function this one
right here that will call our Co routine
and again over and over and over and
over until we create here a public void
cancel spawning and in our canceled
spawning we are simply going to cancel
so cancel invoke passing here the start
spawning invoke Co routine that well we
are going to cancel and when we start
our game right here in the start
function we are going to spawn it after
0.5 seconds so 0.5 of a second and we
will start spawning and spawning and
spawning now before we test this out and
see if this actually works and it will
work we are going to go here and we're
going to create a public void increase
of increase score and here simply we are
going to say score count plus plus in
our score text dot text is equal to
score column plus score count and this
right here will be called inside of our
snake so when we go in our
playercontroller when we pick up a fruit
you see here we are going to call our
game play controller so game play
controller that instance that in Currys
score just like that so simply call it
to increase the score and by the way
notice here if I go and run our game I'm
going to hit the play button so now
after 0.5 of a second you see here we
have a bomb we have a fruit so here I'm
going to pick up a fruit another bomb
fruit right here let me try to pick it
up so fruit here now one thing that you
are probably noticing is that these game
objects are staying in the scene they
are not being deactivated until we pick
them up or until we touch the bomb and
eventually we will run out of places
where we can walk or move because of the
bomb now because of that we need to go
in our scripts and here I'm going to
create a new folder for our pick up
scripts and simply here I'm going to
create the activate pickup so c-sharp
script deactivate pick up inside of this
script we are simply going to create two
functions are actually one function
called void deactivate which is going to
do what game object set active so that
set not game play controller game object
and this is what I hate so Visual Studio
crashed on me for some reason so we need
to wait for it to reload again when this
happens I simply close Visual Studio
this happens also with monodevelop
I hate it when this happens it simply
freezes
will not take into consideration
monobehaviour monodevelop whatever but
now it works because now you see I can
call our game object set active is false
and in the start I am going to invoke
our deactivate after random range so
random that range between 3 seconds and
6 seconds so between 3 seconds and 6
seconds we are going to deactivate our
game objects now as we did or did we go
here in our gameplay controller and we
called here increased score actually I
did not even tested that out I didn't
did not see we were looking at our
fruits but pay attention now so pay
attention to the score when you start
picking out fruit you see score is not 1
and let us try to pick this up and now
score is 2 and again our fruits and our
bombs are not being deactivated because
silly me
select them right here in the prefabs
and attach the deactivate pick up script
so if I hit the play button now and pay
attention to the score again so when we
start picking out fruits we will start
also counting the score so now score is
1 score is 2 and you see the fruits are
disappearing I almost caught that one on
did I cut this one I think I did ok this
one I missed 4 okay this one I missed 5
and you see it is working so we are
counting the score everything is going
perfectly well what we need to do now is
actually stop a game when we hit one of
these so either wall bomb or tail so
when we hit one of these we simply
whatever what we are going to do is we
are going to say time not to tome but
the time that time skill is zero we are
going to stop our game then you can
restart the game by using your code or
either press the button restarted
because I'm not gonna go we did this
already in the Mary's of times
restarting the game
menus I do this extensively in the
ultimate game development Academy so you
have all of the resources you need to
create your own mechanism for restarting
the game so on and so forth because what
I'm going to do now is go in unity and
I'm going to hit here or double click
and create an audio manager script and
going back in our scripts folder and
helper scripts right click I am going to
create a c-sharp script which I'm going
to call Audio Manager and attach it on
the Audio Manager
game object so simply drag and drop it
on the Audio Manager and what do we have
in our Audio Manager well first of all
let me just tag the class gave a little
bit of space we are also going to make
him an instance so we are going to see
here public static audio manager
instance instance like this and here we
are simply going to create void make
instance so if instance is equal to null
we're simply going to say instance is
equal to this in our awake function we
are going to call make instance and that
is that this is for our instance and we
are also going to have our public audio
clip for our pick up sound and for our
dead sound and for these two we are
simply going to have a public void play
why are you correcting me so public void
play underscore pick up sound like this
and we are going to call here audio
source play clip at point the clip is
pick up sound at Point transform that
position and I'm going to duplicate it
paste it here this is going to be play
dead sound and simply here inside of the
pick up sound we are going to
our dead sound and it's simple like that
and for our sounds go in the Audio
Manager and for our pickup so pickup
sound is going to be our eat fruit sound
and for our dead sound we are going to
have game over sound too so game over
sound number two this is what we have
for our sounds moving back in our script
for the player controller here when we
increase the score we are also going to
call our audio manager that instance to
play the pickup sound and here we're
going to call our audio manager that
instance to play the dead sound
practically we are done with our game if
I go back here and I'm going to pump up
the volume so that we can hear the
sounds so now when we pick up our fruit
pay attention let me just try to pick
one of these up it's like an eating
eating sound you see I had to stop there
because I was about to pick up a fruit
and again and again and again and we can
pick them up and notice when I hit the
wall the game is stopped
we don't spawn anything anymore you can
we did create here a function in our
gameplay controller so we created this
to cancel our spawning we did not call
it because we're using here time scale
in our gameplay controller when the time
scale is set to zero instantiate will
not work but if you want to implement
something else you can call cancel
invoke you can stop the game with the
boolean whatever you choose and that is
that basically so in our game play
controller we did nothing new we just
created here our instance we attached
our pickup prefabs I've explained how I
got these values this is the text for
the score and the score count here we
simply have a cool routine that based on
the random value will either spawn a
fruit or spawn a bomb invoke spawning
which will call this function again to
start the same cool routine increasing
the score here
for our audio manager simply playing the
pickup sounds and the dead sound by
using play clip at point we created also
script to deactivate our pickups after
three or six or between three and six
seconds here for our playercontroller
simply we called those functions to play
the sounds and to display the score and
we explained everything else in the
previous videos so again I'm going to
hit the play button so we can see this
in action one more time so here is one
of our pickups I'm going to try to die
this time by eating or touching my own
tail so I ate this come on come on come
on this and this and this this also oh I
missed that one yeah I died now you see
here you see how he died we should have
passed this here the reason for this is
because my Collider for my eyeball or
this one to do the first the snake's
head is too large you can resize it so
the radius is set at 1 or actually for
this snake this dude right here excuse
me so the radius is set at point 11 you
can resize it let me just go in the
scene and search for the snake you can
resize it to something like point 0 9
which is smaller so if I hit the play
button so now our collider is smaller we
can still pick things off so we can eat
here the fruit as you just saw so we can
eat the fruit but when we try to pass
our own tail then it will work because
let me just try to make the snake a
little bit bigger to demonstrate that so
we ate this we ate this and let me just
ate this or eat this as well and let me
try it ok now it worked you see now we
are not dead by going right near our
tail but we will be that if I do this
and bam we have died again this is our
small 3d snake game this is how simple
it is if you had this idea when the
Nokia phone came out probably we will be
millionaires but hey we did not came
with that idea first so just learned
something from this tutorial in this
game that we have created for your hair
from awesome dudes calm I will see you
guys in the next video